son ya 35 días en protestas
prácticamente consecutivas no solo en
Caracas sino el interior del país se
trata de trabajadores públicos del
sector salud maestros también del sector
transporte ellos ganan en promedio entre
seis y doce dólares mensuales lo que no
les alcanza ni siquiera para cubrir sus
necesidades de alimentación en promedio
la canasta básica a finales del año
pasado en Venezuela cerró en 500 dólares
mensuales ellos además se han acercado
acá a los alrededores del Ministerio de
Educación porque querían rechazar el
recién aprobado proyecto de ley que
permitiría a estudiantes de bachillerato
ejercer la docencia aseguran que esto
viola la Constitución no han podido no
han podido llegar al ministerio porque
piquetes de la Policía Nacional
bolivariana se han apostado en los
alrededores para impedirles el paso
estos trabajadores aseguran que se van a
mantener en las calles hasta que sus
demandas sean escuchadas pues es
imposible sobrevivir en el país con esos
salarios